honestly when I looked at this question
like I don't know I think I was just
tired I just didn't understand what was
going on like it's not a complicated
diagram it's not complicated at all
right but if you're like I don't I'm
just overwhelmed by the paragraph of
what's important here okay so let's
begin this is all we required to prove
right
they give us they give us a pair of
parametric equations right but the pair
equations relates to this point P okay
so what they want is x equals this and y
equals this okay now that's just another
way of saying that the coordinates of
this point up here are this and and this
that's what it's asking for okay
now once you know that the rest of it is
quite accessible okay for instance like
the X values already handed to you right
the x value of P because it forms a
rectangle up here is the same as the x
value of C right so I would literally
say like for me my proof I would say as
a CPV is a rectangle right like I'm
using that geometric property
therefore I could say that peace shares
the same x-coordinate as see right so I
would say X of P equals X of C and so
that's the actual value right next
equals to I might I might leave that on
that point there because I'm gonna have
a couple more for you so that fits easy
ok now in exactly the same way how am I
going to get this where does it come
from look at the diagram why it comes
from this that's incredibly unhelpfully
named okay so I'm gonna rename it top
HSC question I'm gonna call it Y of B
just saw not in the US okay now how is
be defined right well it starts down
yeah right Hawaiian comes up then it's
perpendicular okay
so that's my one two steps okay your
steps to get this light I'm going to
start with this so what's the gradient
of AC gradient basic it's um it's rise
over one isn't it so it's zero take away
negative K do you hear that
/ t take aways here and there's the run
okay so what got excuse me okay / T but
I don't know what that line I'm just
using that lines of stepping started to
get to this line right what's the
gradient if this is the gradient of AC
what's the gradient of BC so I'm gonna
say since AC is perpendicular to BC I'm
just taking the negative reciprocal that
gradient is minus T over K which of
course is very promising
alright I'm almost there now what do I
do with this gradient where am I going
to use it I know that it has this
gradient the line I'm interested in and
apostolates are in that point right
there you see that point so I will say
therefore the equation of line BC that's
what I'm after right that one there
I'm just going to use point grading form
because I know it's great yet and I know
quickly it goes through so the point is
T 0 so I'll go Y minus y1
there's y1 equals M
that's the great need I just determined
outside of X minus x1 that's the
x-coordinate I go through you see that
and you can see where my t-square okay
comes from y equals minus T on K X plus
because there's a double negative
teaspoon okay but then I just have to
say what B is the y intercept of this
line the y-intercept of dislike right B
is the y-intercept
Oh BC right I already know what it's
excellent is because it's a Hawaii set
but now I know what its y-coordinate is
right so therefore Y of a equals T
squared okay I simply read that from
there and so therefore Y of P also
equals tsp okay for the same reason that
I had up here because it's a rectangle
okay